[Music]
in fake dock news because big dog
documentary wait how did I say it you
didn't say it it it's just that word
that like because oh it's dog dock dock
for our ship so we like we just say what
up dog doctor no you said it fine like a
quack-quack
I think dr. Mason let's see submitted by
Jojo I think doctor what's arrest after
claiming to cure pretty much all the
diseases using a patient's own blood I
believe it was this in China this
somewhere else yeah let's drink your own
blood why China was China watched a Miss
China Mexico they take all your blood
and then I'll throw it through this
machine centrifuge sure for your face
and then and then I put the blood back
in you and they also do with kids blood
I've heard of blood yeah that's a
cologne I don't want kids blood it
probably smells like [ __ ] mac and
cheese they'd supposed to make you look
young I can feel you I would you smell
the Tracy but how are you thinking well
I don't know I feel like people would
relieve anything when it comes to like
very risky situations you know any mean
like when they're about to die oh yeah
they'll try anything like just I'll like
a donkey's butthole let's go oh that's
true because it's gonna save you I mean
I'm just trying to paint the actual
picture I solve your cancer get some
pink guy hey I'm down if I get the
cancer out [ __ ] I'm not gonna like it
let's go you even [ __ ] Bo if it could
trigger that effect on me and I get
cured I'll do it we look at like a
donkey's butthole yep you'd go in like
that you'd be like no I'm gonna [ __ ]
suck the [ __ ] out of it like you don't
suck it certainly sounds like if that's
gonna kill you just lick it
eat the flies around it - yeah don't let
it go to waste
mr. Miyagi's power I had she would do
chopsticks alright so this man from
Florida oh my god Jaipur no he was
posing at it as a doctor claiming that
he could cure diabetes Parkinson's
disease leukemia like literally
everything got skills yes his name is
Oh Nelly Oh 73 years old he was like
advertising his services on a website in
El clasificado oh my gosh how'd I know I
know all right how do I know how do you
why do you think I thought it was just
somebody for Mexico but I mean it could
be any Latin countries that we believe
had a lot of things is that the
Pennysaver for Mexicans pretty much yeah
yeah yeah I see that on the floor
somewhere someone from the Florida
Department of Health
posed as a patient of his and so that's
why no nelio tech cover the patient's
blood pressure and the pulse and then
placed a band around the patient's head
and then had him hold a metal rod and so
these things the band in the middle rod
were connected to a machine on a table
and then he turned on the machine I
started making beeping noises Wow it's a
metal detector
this guy's motives is it money and
definitely I mean or does he believe
he's got some [ __ ] what if he's crazy
and he just thinks like I'm a healer
put this up your butt hole and uh put
that put that one in your ear hole and
then uh spin around three times and
you're never getting cancer
it's definitely money I can guarantee it
do you think they know they're conning
people a hundred percent I thought maybe
he's just a believer in his own powers
yeah I am there's witch doctors out
there yeah but they're not gonna make
you do that yeah maybe hold some may
hold some metal Oh Ricky what do you
know about Ricky I dunno what's Ricky
you basically lay there and then they go
like this they move your energy don't
even touch you yeah I I did it twice ha
ha it work I don't know is that cheese
stuff and let me feeling weird sounds
like I think it worked I think I feel
good again to make sure as long as it
makes you'll be charged you it was
pretty Paige okay not that much of a I
don't wanna prove any is to everybody
here but it was like $60 like a nice
massage penny
yeah can I be touched I was like I mean
how long was the happy ending it I
rather pay
okay it's a it was an hour but it was
crazy because okay so like I have knee
pain right because like from playing
sports my whole life and she'd be like
oh we need to move energy to your knee
and I was like oh are you holding a
crystal huh no she's or did you fill out
a survey to say what are the spots that
hurt you no no I really did it Olympic
ya know what's crazy is that like she
wouldn't move to like let's say my feet
and I would feel like heat on my feet so
you're focusing energies crazy y'all
like we really don't know have the
things no no we like it was like another
$60 I'll be back in a week it makes you
feel better I actually think it doesn't
matter if it's a scam yeah you got you
got your value out of just really felt
like I was like oh [ __ ] like I feel like
I don't know what I'm supposed to feel I
don't I can't put a word to it you're
torn ACL is fixed up but it was my my it
was done by my therapist so I trusted
her you know what I mean so I was like
alright this is I trust this guy so he
tested his brain activity his intestinal
system did he make the sound from his
mouth to like so then he said that his
cholesterol was on the rise that he
wasn't getting enough oxygen delivered
to his brain his liver was 50% fats his
gallbladder
rate was declining and then on top of
all of that he had diabetes and
osteoporosis was all this correct though
imagine he's like he was right I think
it was so then he told the patient that
he could cure all these things or at
least his diabetes if you paid him
$2,000 for future treatments including
blood injections so he said that got
scary draw the blood from the person and
then injected back into the person I'm
not going to go to it no and then once
it goes back into the person that's when
the blood does some [ __ ] to your body
and cures things see that's the kind of
[ __ ] that's dangerous because you don't
know what kind of use sterilizing needle
it meant and
for $2,000 per patient I would buy a
muni know every time yeah but i don't
know if he's clean is it right but if
he's posting in the there's like a stem
machine tells you see like Joe your I
gotta read your conscience right now
grab the handle are you happy yeah me no
you're not one more grand adult fiction
so funny I went to this therapist who
practice out of a hair salon she like
her mom would go to this lady all the
time
so and I already know what to go around
talking about yeah thank you so then
when we went there I was talking to his
therapist but before she did anything to
me she told me this similar [ __ ] she
took she put some [ __ ] on my head and
then she made me hold onto this metal
rod and she was like reading my energy
or some [ __ ] that wasn't the same school
she's a Scientologist I think she was or
something because then I end up just
talking to her and I was just like all
right fine
so I'm here I have a lot of [ __ ] bottled
up and I just let it live so then after
an hour I think it was she's read my
energy again she was like yeah you know
you got to keep coming to these sessions
way better I know I'm like I'm never
coming back but yeah it was funny cuz
like so many people do fall for that
yeah it's the same technique the band in
the metal handle boy or something to it
dude remember the Asian though Asian
women that we're getting scammed that
they would get their jewelry give it to
this person and then they would read
their fortune and then they were like
okay give it to us we're gonna do
something with it and we'll give it back
like you know this ring this expensive
ring it's tainted yes see so let me go
bless this yeah what I taught the
diamonds yeah they were like don't open
that we're gonna give you back your
jewelry but don't open it okay don't
open it right away let it sit for a
couple of days or else it's gonna all
come back and these poor old ladies
would do that and they'd wait and
there's the jewelry's gone
what was it rocks maybe but they bounced
that's right I just think when people
have little hope they looked for
anything for sure if he's talking about
like cancer yeah
but it sounds like they went to this guy
not knowing they had anything well I
remember he diagnosing him ya know ya
saw the person the patient was from the
Florida Department of Health so they
were it was like a sting operation but I
wanted the other guys money just showed
up because they saw it in the ad as a
normal doctor and thought it was cheap I
guess who also gets her doctor from a
piece of [ __ ] my [ __ ] newspaper I
think one too okay so one time when I
was younger my mom knew of this guy who
she found out about the church it was at
the Swami so you would go to this one
know grab some $10 Ray Ban we fell for
it we went to saw Mina he would see you
he like grabbed me he like press here
press there you know first of all but
now he's like oh your liver and this and
that and then after he would be like
okay you need these vitamins these
vitamins these vitamins and then I ended
up paying like $120 in vitamins and like
cleansing and stuff you know you just
did here is a part of Herbalife yeah he
was part of Herbalife yeah and you're
just like okay well I don't want to I
want to make sure I don't get like liver
cancer so yeah let me take the vitamins
you know how come you guys don't
question culture like real doctors that
are qualified sometimes I think they're
pulling some [ __ ] because of political
and who they're getting paid by by
prescriptions and like they're pushing
certain prescriptions because their boss
to tell me that that's a jet dude like I
don't want it a doctor I'm like take it
away
yeah I hate who's my body she's like
[ __ ] nah he's not doing it right
we're one I'm right you could do that
because okay so like a doctor right is
like you there's a lot of different
certification yeah you hope so you you
you you hope that they're they're
weeding it out so like you don't have to
be critical of that sadly they do this
is someone I could swap me grow like
that's true
yeah true
different because we talked about you
didn't pass those please but yeah there
be some on a real doctor Afghanistan
yeah yeah they go through classics they
go through qualification they go through
licensing there's a board and all of
that is very different from somebody
that's doing magic on a street corner I
still this right even system yeah what's
a Vitamix is like take this little
chewable bear but now you have to
scrutinize every sadly the doctor's
office and you're like why you giving me
these bro you didn't even check my
[ __ ] poster do you think my blood
pressure he starts giving me all these
pills yeah everyone's like oh you
definitely need a statin you're 30 years
old all right now nowadays because all
the stuff I know through Fitness like if
I go to see like a sports medicine
doctor or physical therapist or
chiropractor or not like a knee pain and
they go oh you shouldn't squat any more
than I don't even know what you're doing
like I've had back issues for a long
time and I know they're gonna tell me
one or two things don't squat or your
you need surgery the ones that don't
know what they're doing sirs cuz pro
athletes they have the craziest injuries
and they're still playing and training
and ER sure they just don't they just
don't have the tools to help me with my
god I got wet WebMD
I don't need you I just need doctors to
prescribe me antibiotics that's it yeah
oh yeah go to TJ see we're just talking
shout out this on me
[Music]